the European Space Agency is meeting in
Paris to outline its priorities for the
next years and renewable energy
generation is high on the agenda more
specifically one idea would see solar
energy sent wirelessly down to earth
have a look
an idea that's out of this world the
European space agency has a vision of a
system to capture energy from the sun's
rays in orbit and beam it back home the
back down on Earth the reality is it's a
vision for the future but how far in the
future the idea of extraterrestrial
power plants has been around for decades
since then our technological
capabilities in space have reached new
highs
and prices for things like satellites
are a fraction of what they once were a
major obstacle to overcome is the
wireless transmission of energy through
the Earth's atmosphere and the vacuum of
space experts say it could be two
decades before the solution is Within
Reach
John Dominic cost is the senior manager
for airbus's Blue Sky division that's
the one that deals with future
Technologies welcome Jean Dominique
first off are we really going to see
space-based solar energy become a
mainstream source of power generation
hello Janelle
um well I believe so
um actually the what you heard in the um
in the initial jingle two decades that
is the current timeline we believe that
this could be really operational in his
grandest form in um by the you know by
the time we reached 2040 and by this
time this is the timeline for having a
station that is really powering a city
uh we're talking about sending gigawatts
of power
um but on the way to get there there's a
the road is quite uh long and we see a
lot of interesting application already
to power small things like drones
airplanes factories uh small satellites
so we can already demonstrate some
applications of that technology in the
next two to three years
now I have to ask are there any concerns
around safety is there any Risk
Technology like this can be weaponized
at all or have I just seen too many
movies
so the indeed the the energy will be
sent via beams uh so these are it's not
not exactly lasers like the like the one
from the Death Star Star Wars at all uh
we're talking here
um rays of microwave energy so microwave
typically it's something that you do not
see
um and that has a lot less let's say
power uh density as something like laser
so it's really the amount of energy you
send is really it only distributed and
in a way that's
you you could actually just walk through
to be without much hustle
um now if you really want to be
extremely safe you can also already put
some measures like uh using a radar
system to look at anything that could
come close to the beam itself and to
stop the beam when somebody would come
up with but so far when we have rock
also with people doing regulation for
the energy sector we do not see this as
an issue
that's reassuring I'll take your word
for it so when European ministers table
this project later today like we've been
talking about what are you expecting
um so I expect that they will agree to
fund a technology program on which you
have technology bricks that are needed
to get to that space-based solar power
concept the beauty of that is that this
technology breaks they're really pushing
the boundary of of space technology else
of Power Electronics of um you know
antennas and things like that so by
putting money on this technology bricks
you already you know enable applications
for a lot of things that are are used in
space missions so we expect them to
agree on funding this technology bricks
so you get some on you know on new
antennas on power generation things like
that and we also expect them to agree on
a uh what do you call a system study
which is an effort to really look at the
end-to-end viability of the concept on a
technological viewable on an
environmental and sustainability View
and finally why is Airbus interested in
this particular Endeavor what does
Airbus get out of it
so yeah it's really good question so
Abbas as an aerospace company uh has now
a mission for a few years to really
Pioneer sustainability in Aerospace so
the you know in aviation
sustainability is the next big thing
um we we want to be able to decarbonize
the industry we want to lead that
transformation and we want to lead that
across the board of aviation in space so
for us this is an extremely good case of
using space or Aerospace derive
technology to uh to bring sustainability
to the world so we really believe in
that
um then on top of that we see
interesting applications so to you know
new business to uh to enter the energy
markets and to be able to provide you
know new energy networks over the sky
and over the air and of our space which
we do together with Partners in the
energy sector and uh a bit closer to our
industry we um we would love to power
aircraft with that
Jean Dominique cost he's the senior
manager for Airbus Blue Sky division
thank you very much for your insights
now it's not only industrial giants like
Airbus who are conquering space or
billionaires as the trend seems to go
space technology can also present
opportunities for startups without much
Financial backing meet Julian Fernandez
who built his first satellite in his
bedroom
Julian Fernandez is 19 years old While
others were meeting up to play sports or
hang around Julian was using a soldering
iron to build himself a mini satellite
I launched the first one into space when
I was 16. it's about the size of a
Rubik's Cube
I have a replica here
it works like a radio tower in space
at his Madrid University Fernandez could
use equipment that he didn't have at
home
it was a milestone to have launched my
own satellite at 16 to have raised the
money myself I had even gathered all the
knowledge online in forums and
scientific papers
Vicente Gonzalez co-founded fossa
systems with Fernandez giving up his
permanent job to do so he's just 27
years old but youth has its advantages
and disadvantages
many companies find it interesting when
the founder and the CEO are under 30.
but of course it's also difficult after
all our competitors are ohb Airbus and
Boeing
Fernandez's idea transmitting small
amounts of data easily and cheaply data
from agricultural sensors or from remote
wind power plants the data is radioed to
the satellite and forwarded along it's
all about the Internet of Things
I decided to democratize access to
communication channels and the internet
of things through space
fossil systems now has 23 employees
earlier this year they celebrated
another Milestone when a SpaceX rocket
carried their satellites on board
now we have 13 satellites in orbit
they're a little bit bigger they're
evolved
Julian Fernandez may be heading a
satellite business that competes with
giants but every now and then he has to
step out and take on another role
my knowledge is very specific I still
have to go to university to study
math calculus algebra there's still Lots
I have to learn
but even before he graduates with his
telecommunications engineering degree
Fernandez will have his next batch of
satellites launched into space by 2024
he hopes his network of Spanish
microsatellites will be orbiting the
world not bad for a 21st birthday
present